as our political rulers celebrate the
slaughter of babies and castration of
children they've got a new plan to
thwart threats to our nation and that is
to
stop Catholics from going to mass
according to an FBI document it's leaked
by former agent Kyle Serafin the
nation's top domestic law enforcement
agency considers Catholics and
specifically Catholics who attend the
traditional mass the mass that defined
Western Civilization for nearly two
Millennia to be radical but potentially
violent extremists now as one of those
Fringe radicals who attends the
traditional Mass I can tell you there
are plenty of threats for starters many
people who attend the traditional Mass
have families often with multiple babies
so the odds of slipping on a pacifier
and hitting your head on the floor of
the church are very real there are
sensors at the mass durables to use the
technical term so at any point you might
start coughing on that fragrant incense
and if that weren't enough just before
the mass the priest walks down the aisle
and sprinkles people with hyssop to
symbolize the cleansing of our souls and
the water could
like get in your eye or something like
that
a lot of threats now some people have
pointed out
law enforcement might be put to better
use arresting the criminals who burn our
country down and kill lots of people
like BLM did for eight months straight
or stopping the international criminal
cabals flooding our country with
gangsters and poison and two million
trafficked human beings per year as the
cartels do across our Southern border or
taking down the elite pedo Rings like
Jeffrey Epstein's which operated with
relative impunity and apparent Federal
sanction for years on end
but how could the FBI devote any
attention to those minor problems when a
handful of Christians are worshiping God
the way that they have for two thousand
years
our political rulers recognize that they
need to keep their priorities in order
and those rulers the principalities and
powers of this world have made their
priorities perfectly clear a Michael
knows this the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Mike Burgess
who says I heard that if you play the
state of the union and Black Sabbath
Paranoid backwards at the same time you
can summon Sam Smith that's true
actually that's that's scientifically
proven to be true even though it is the
stuff of nightmares now when you want to
have a good night's sleep you got to
check out Helix right now head on over
to helixsleep.com Knowles with
everything going on in the world right
now you could use a good night's sleep
that's why you got to check out Helix
mattress Helix is a premium mattress
brand that provides tailored mattresses
based on your unique sleep preferences
the Helix lineup includes 14 unique
mattresses including a collection of
luxury models a mattress for Big and
Tall sleepers and even a mattress made
just for kids I have had my Helix for
years I absolutely love it it's a
fabulous mattress super easy you don't
need to worry about buying a mattress
online I was a little nervous about that
elix has a sleep quiz matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress because why would you
buy a mattress made for somebody else go
right now to helixsleep.com Knowles take
their two minute sleep quiz find the
perfect mattress for your body and sleep
type your mattress will come right to
your door for free
plus Helix has a 10-year warranty and
you get to try it out for 100 nights
risk-free they will even pick it up for
you if you don't love it but you will
love it Helix has over twelve thousand
five star reviews they're financing
options and flexible payment plans make
it so that a great night's sleep is
never far away
Helix is giving our listeners right now
20 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows hurry over to helixsleep.com
Knowles with Helix better sleep starts
now
speaking of crime well you know all
those terrible crimes of Christians
going and worshiping God in the
traditional way of to Millennia there's
some other crimes
going around our culture and a lot of
people are defending those crimes uh
there's a documentary out from Vice the
left-wing Magazine Media Company
in which Libs make an argument
explicitly that they've been making
implicitly for many many years namely
that if you if you criticize crime
you're actually criticizing a race and a
culture
statistically it is true that Asians
right on average make more money like in
terms of medium make more money better
test scores get into better colleges all
that stuff I think the question is why
is that and I don't know if model
minority whatever that label wants
that's actually a myth because we cannot
be um well no listen well let me finish
my point we need to observe what makes
people successful and unsuccessful and I
think when you look at trends that are
generally true in the Asian Community
not of everyone but are generally true
usually you have families that are
sticking together you have
um you know people are taught to work
hard in school not get into trouble I
think that translates to why Asians on
Master are successful and I don't think
you have to be Asian or white for that
matter to not have kids out of wedlock
not you know commit crime not not cause
trouble or whatever it is it's just a
matter of like well common sense that's
what makes people successful and if
that's so-called assimilation having a
nuclear family buying a house going to
school whatever it is then yeah okay
call me a pro simulation then I think
there's a difference between
assimilation and Erasure yes
yes there it is right there at the end
throughout the whole clip if you were
only listening to it you weren't able to
watch the just beautiful Expressions on
the faces of all the libs on the panel
says you know I just think probably
people shouldn't have kids at a wedlock
and they should get married and they
should do well in school and they should
not commit crimes and you look on the
people's faces they say oh is he really
is he really telling people not to
commit crimes is he oh my gosh what is
he and then at the end at the very very
tail end of that clip you get the thrust
of the libs argument they say well look
come on
what you're talking about that's not
assimilation that's Erasure
Erasure is the the lib term that that
describes when you disrespect and erase
a different cultural groups and racial
groups is usually how it's applied
which is to say the libs are suggesting
that crime is just an integral part of
certain races and cultures which set
that sounds like the kind of argument
that if we said it they would call that
racist but they're they're the ones who
are saying it and it is not true it is
not true
our society says that though our society
says that good culture is a crime
and that criminal culture is good
our society says that people going to
mass with their families to worship God
on Sunday that that is tantamount to a
crime it's violent extremism it's
terrorism let's go sick the feds on
those Catholics
but people who are committing actual
crimes robberies looting murder that
that's just their culture and we can't
tell anyone that their culture is bad
and we need to let them off the hook and
BLM goes and burns the country down for
eight months well let's let's drop the
charges come on society made them do
that come on actually we supported it
ourselves we Elites running Society
that's where we are completely upside
down
you see this double standard of Justice
especially clearly this week over at the
Oklahoma state capitol now
listen I'm an old man now I'm getting
older by the minute and so I'm old
enough to remember when showing up and
making a giant nuisance of yourself at a
capital was called a coup d'etat an
Insurrection treason sort of thing where
you need to be arrested and thrown in
solitary confinement
but turns out that's that's only the
case when it's conservatives who show up
to the Capitol when it is leftists who
show up to the Capitol that is a
wonderful thing and you saw that this
week the trans lives matter
demonstrators occupied the Oklahoma
Capitol building
they occupied it to protest
republican-backed bills that would ban
tranzing the kids
it would ban sex change operations for
people under the age of 26. the argument
being that people's brains aren't fully
developed until they're 25 so you're
going to ban those surgeries until the
brains are developed I think they should
be banned for everybody nobody has a
right to chop off his genitals it's a
very cruel and absurd society that would
encourage
people to chop off their their genitals
of any age not just little kids so 150
protesters from a bunch of different
groups show up to the Oklahoma Capitol
and they're there and they're screaming
and they're yelling and they've got
their signs and they're chanting and
they're they're far less Whimsical than
the smiley guy with the podium the
lectern at the January 6th or the horn
hat guy they're they're actually somehow
more eccentric even than the horn hat
guy
uh but this is lauded as a wonderful
thing and that's always the case that's
always the case and it's really just a
reminder for the squishes it's not a
reminder for the libs they know that
they have two tiers of Justice they're
they're behind it they're the ones who
are enforcing different rules and
conservatives than on leftists the real
conservatives we know that there are two
systems of Justice if you go out and
trans the kids and have a
homage to the prince of lies and with
the fires of Hell at the Grammys the
first lady is going to be there
everyone's going to be applauding that's
going to be a wonderful thing but if you
show up to the traditional Mass on
Sunday the feds are going to be there
you know try trying to uh entrap you you
say how do you do fellow Catholics any
of you want to do some terrorism today
oh no I'm just asking I don't want to go
get a bagel after and talk about
terrorism that that's the way that it
goes they know that it's the squishes in
the middle who don't get it
it's the squishes in the middle who buy
the propaganda
who say oh well
that horn hat guy maybe he really is
Osama Bin Laden oh I don't know I mean
when you really think about it taking a
funny picture with a chorus light or a
Nancy Pelosi lectern in the capital
rotunda that kind of is tantamount to an
act of terrorism or a coup d'etat no of
course it's not
of course it's not speaking of transient
people and state capitals gotta give a
shout out to Walsh Walsh had a
magnificent performance yesterday over
here in Tennessee at the Tennessee State
Capitol he uh he showed up to talk about
it was there was a bill that was up
about transgenderism and Walsh Walsh
just showed up he's a citizen of
Nashville and the the Democrats thought
that they could entrap him they thought
that they could own Matt Walsh with
facts and logic did not turn out well
for them
so I'm curious if 16 is a a an adult in
your view why is this bill have the
minor defined as 18.
yeah that's that's a hit piece you took
from Media Matters uh from something
when I was a radio host uh 13 14 years
ago in my early 20s uh it's also not an
accurate reflection of what I actually
said I was talking about
uh the fact that people tended to marry
young historically and that's all that
that was about
um
how does that relate to this
subject
just curious your definition of if you
feel like people are adults at 16 should
people are adults at 18. but actually
they're your your brain is not fully
developed until you're 25.
so we should be having a conversation
about whether we should even be doing
these surgeries to people at 18. but
certainly before 18 it's it's absurd I
mean do you do you think that a 16 year
old can meaningfully consent to having
their body parts removed
do you
no
we do not yeah we ask the questions it's
not it's uh representative Hammer you
are recognized
absolutely devastating I I knew it was
going to go bad when the Democrat opened
his mouth because he was unsure of
himself he clearly as Walsh pointed out
he had this gotcha that he he got from
skimming and Media Matters or splc or
one of these left-wing hit organizations
and or a hit job on Matt so you you once
you met you said a thing on the radio
about how 16 year olds used to get
married so and so you know like um so
what do you come on what do you think
about that and Walsh just absolutely
pile drives this poor this poor Democrat
state senator and he said so okay all
right well here's the explanation of the
line that you took out of context for
Media Matters um but just let's just
talk about the question here at the
hearing do you really think a 16 year
old can consent to having her body parts
removed
and the Democrats like
somebody help me and then the other the
other state senator or whoever this
person is we asked the questions here
yeah right maybe maybe you would be
better legislators Democrats if you had
answers as well as I know you got a lot
of questions you're confused about a lot
of things and Walsh went there and
provided pretty simple answers it's not
pretty basic stuff guys you don't need
to have a PhD in a Dr fauci white lab
coat and a stethoscope and you can just
you can have eyes
we have eyes and common sense to see the
boys and girls are different you know I
can tell sometimes I don't want to tell
Tales out of the Boudoir but when I put
on my pajamas at night all right Lisa
puts on her pajamas you can it's just
they're different you know okay you can
tell that men and women are different
and when when you want to uh indulge
that difference and the the Indulgence
of very lovely pajamas you gotta check
out Pajamagram right now go to
pajamagram.com use code nude
this Valentine's Day give your lady the
gift of silky naturally nude pajamas
available exclusively at Pajamagram even
more alluring than lingerie the texture
and touch of these pajamas are so soft
that you'll both love the feel of them
if you have no idea what to get your
girlfriend or wife for Valentine's Day
trust me she wants these pajamas and you
want her to have them go to
pajamagram.com right now use code nude
to save 25 off your order of naturally
nude pajamas Pajamagram will even wrap
the whole gift up for free if you missed
out on this offer during Christmas do
not make the same mistake twice they do
sell out give her naturally nude pajamas
you need to order today they sold out
last year before Valentine's Day so do
it right now pajamagram.com use code
nude
n-u-d-e for 25 off don't forget to tell
them that I sent you
speaking of transiting people
Ron DeSantis
announced the conclusion of a plan that
he had declared a year ago
Ron DeSantis is taking self-government
away from Disney
's gonna pay its debt and I think if you
remember when we did the initial special
session where we set the Sunset date and
we knew we'd have to deal with this I
always said that they're going to come
in and we're going to we're going to
figure out the best way to do it uh so
so what I said really for the last six
nine months is
Disney is no longer going to have
self-government they're not going to
have their own government Disney is
going to pay its fair share of taxes and
Disney's going to honor the debt and
that's exactly what this proposed piece
of legislation will do if you remember
when we first went down this road last
spring a lot of folks in the media were
saying that oh my gosh Disney's actually
going to pay less taxes and Floridians
are going to pay more taxes they were
saying that and I'm like you've got to
be kidding me well this puts that to bed
and so those debts will be honored and
those will be paid now this is obviously
now going to be controlled by the state
of Florida which is no longer
self-governing for them so there's a new
sheriff in town and that's just the way
it's going to be
really really good look in practice what
this means is that Disney for the last
half century or more has had control of
the local government of the district
that Disney World operates in and what
DeSantis has done is take over the
district take it back from Disney so
Florida Republicans will have DeSantis
appointing all five leaders of Disney's
tax District in Orlando and they will
rename the district so it will no longer
be called the Reedy Creek improvement
district which is what it had been
called it'll now be the central Florida
tourism oversight district and the
reason this matters
for DeSantis in particular is it shows
follow through
it's not just an announcement when he
announced it last year I thought oh this
is a good political stunt this looks
good it's the right idea okay fine
but then he actually followed through
with it he doesn't really get a new
headline out of the announcement
yesterday I mean we're talking about it
some people will talk about it but it's
not a new news story he already
announced that this would happen the
difference is now he's following through
which is important if he is going to run
for president in 2024 it looks like he
is he'll be able to point and say look I
don't just have the right gut instincts
I don't just come out with big
announcements that grab headlines but I
actually follow through with them you
can trust me to do what I am promising
you that I will do the other reason that
this looks really good for Ron DeSantis
is it shows that Ron desantis's
conservatism is a conservatism that is
much more comfortable
wielding state power
than the conservatism of many of the
squishes in the party many people in the
Republican Party especially over the
last 20 years their their conservatism
has amounted to hey I'm not going to do
anything you elect me and I'm just
basically going to go home and I'm not
going to the most I'm going to do is
deregulate and give corporations more
power and let them do whatever they want
that that was the heavily libertarian
scented
conservative base movement kind of
conservatism in recent years and
the reason that that was attractive to
people is because big government has
done all sorts of bad things and so we
were reacting against that the other
reason is because we had we've just
fought a cold war for the second half of
the 20th century and so opposition to
big government was something that United
a lot of conservatives because our enemy
was the Soviet Union and communism
we are now seeing
some of the accesses in the other
direction when you privatize everything
when you give woke corporations free
reign to do whatever the hell that they
want that also can hurt conservatives if
it's big government taking my rights
that's bad if it's Google taking my
rights that's also bad it's not if it's
Disney transiting my kids that is just
as bad as if Dr fauci were transing my
kids or Rachelle wolenski or who's that
guy the guy who is the assistant Health
sector Richard Levine that guy it's just
as bad I I don't care whether it's a
public or allegedly private entity
transiting my kids all I care about is
are my kids being trans are my rights
being taken away is my way of life being
upended and a lot of conservatives just
they're not there yet they don't quite
understand how to articulate why it is a
good thing sometimes to wield state
power against corporations Rhonda santis
can do it he can articulate it and he is
actually doing it and the other
Republicans who want to look good coming
into 2020 4 are going to have to get on
the stick
now some Republicans just don't get it
some are you know we talk about the good
Republicans
you know DeSantis I think is doing a
great job you know I love Donald Trump I
think he's the greatest president of my
lifetime you know I like a lot of other
Republicans Ted Cruz in particular love
Ted Cruz and there are a number of
others doing really great work out there
Glenn youngin's doing good work by
Virginia standards
a lot of good stuff then there's some
Republicans not so much I'm talking
about Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney
was walking up at the State of the Union
the other night and one of these little
cat fighty High School cafeteria moments
he walks up to George Santos the
embattled endemically dishonest
republican from Long Island and he says
you don't belong here
see ya there's Santos there and Romney
just turns to his you don't you don't
belong here there's a clip that came out
later
of Romney walking with a gaggle of
reporters and he's angry he's fired up
he says this guy this George Santos
uh yeah you're damn right I gave him a
piece of my mind
yeah
why why
do hands with every senator in the
president United States that's the uh
given given the fact that he's under
ethics investigation he should be
sitting in the back road staying quiet
instead of uh
parading in front of the president and
uh and and people coming into the room
he says he you know that he embellished
This Record look embellishing is saying
you've got an A when you get an A minus
lying is saying you you graduated from a
college you didn't even attend and you
shouldn't be in Congress and uh they're
going to go through the process and
hopefully get him out and uh but he
shouldn't be there and if he had any
shame at all he wouldn't be there why
did you make a point to say that though
I mean I mean it was kind of out of your
way he was standing right there in the
aisle shaking hands with everybody did
he respond to you uh he may have I
didn't hear it
yes yeah let me tell you reporters why I
just this other Republican he's just
absolutely terrible that's right I gave
him a piece of my mind that Republican
it's outrageous that that Republican who
was elected by his constituents is here
serving in the Congress
uh tell you he'll still continue to
serve here Over My Dead Body speaking of
dead bodies you got to go check out epic
will right now go to epicwill.com use
promo code Knowles recent surveys have
revealed that as many as 67 percent of
Americans don't have a will do not be
just another statistic for just 119
bucks and in as little as five minutes
epic will can help you create your last
will and testament living will and even
Health Care power of attorney there's
step-by-step online form makes it
incredibly easy all you've got to do is
fill in the blanks very very important
to have a will I let it go way too long
without having one but if you don't have
a will then you don't know what's going
to happen to your money and your stuff
and most importantly your kids choose
today to be the smarter half of
Americans that do have will go to
epicwill.com use promo code Knowles
kwles to save 10 on Epic Will's complete
will package epicwill.com promo code
k-n-o-w-l-e-s because I can promise you
my friends
you will die someday and you're going to
put it off and put it off and put it off
don't do that don't let that nag it you
have that peace of mind that comes from
knowing that your stuff and your family
are going to be safe
epicwill.com promo code Knowles
Mitt Romney says George Santos doesn't
deserve to serve in Congress because
he's a liar okay fine yeah he is a liar
he's got all these sorts of shady things
in his past
it's kind of like a lame joke at this
point that that lame jokes can be funny
for a little bit and then they become
really really unfunny and then they get
really really funny again that's the Arc
of the of weak jokes that's how I feel
about George Santos
that he got elected and I liked that he
got elected it's cool that a republican
got elected in Long Island and then I
started to not like him because it
turned out he's lied about everything
his education his professional
background probably his sexual desires
he might be under indictment in Brazil
or something I saw a headline about that
and then but then the more that came out
the the more that came out I thought no
this is freaking hilarious I I now get a
huge kick out of this guy
if if the Democrats get their eccentric
figures okay fine George Santos is there
we have a razor thin majority anyway I
get a huge kick out of it
Romney can't he can't take it I say okay
I'm not
it's not that I don't understand
Mitt Romney's
opposition to a republican who lies
about everything
but you just heard the way that he talks
about George Santos
for specifically for lying about his
educational background
now listen to the way that Mitt Romney
talks about Joe Biden who famously had
to drop out of the 1988 presidential
race for lying about his educational
background for plagiarizing for being
the most dishonest politician in the
whole field that year he's Joe Biden one
of the most dishonest politicians in in
the country that's that has been a an
actual distinguishing marker of his
career this is how Romney talks about
him
you know I just got uh back from hearing
the president deliver his State of the
Union Address
um the president's a friend uh I like
Joe Biden uh I have come to know him
over the years and uh and he's a
patriotic man who believes very deeply
and uh the things that he talks about
um I uh I was pleased that he spoke
about Ukraine and about our commitment
to preserve democracy there and around
the world to preserve sovereignty of
Nations
there it is a republican lies in an
over-the-top way this is hideous I'm
going to give him a piece of my mind on
the florines to sit in the back of the
room if he should be kicked out of
Congress
a Democrat lies in a really egregious
way a Democrat who is is a Gideon at the
prospect of slaughtering babies
castrating kids redefining marriage
destroying to say nothing of destroying
the American economy potentially
provoking World War III oh he's
wonderful he's my good friend oh Joe
Biden what a wonderful man I liked the
state of the union he was pretty good
actually
yup there it is there it is you saw this
Romney did the same thing a year or two
years ago
January 6th worst event ever in American
history terrible insurrection
BLM which burned the country down and
killed dozens of people oh I'm gonna go
march with BLM Mitt Romney marched with
BLM
Mitt Romney marched with people who
engaged in a much more serious
Insurrection a much deadlier political
movement in an infinitely deadly or
political movement then January 6th
But Mitt Romney does it because his real
constituents the real people he cares
about
are not as constituents over in Utah
it's not his fellow Republicans in the
U.S Senate it's that group of reporters
all standing around him yeah good job
Matt I've got a strange new respect for
you as you attack Republicans all the
time
comparing those two guys I'm not I'm not
saying that I like George Santos I'm not
saying I'm not saying I I trust the guy
forget as a representative I wouldn't
trust him with my money I wouldn't trust
him with my loved ones I wouldn't trust
him as far as I could throw him but you
tell me right now I can have a George
Santos or a Mitt Romney give me Santos
any day
at least Santos is an honest liar and at
least the Mitt Romney ah gosh awful
at least George Santos is opposing Joe
Biden
at least George Santos
fights the Democrats Mitt Romney oh yeah
Joe Biden is a great friend of mine what
a great guy he is isn't he
speaking of Liberal Republicans
liberal Republican in the house Nancy
mace just came out at a congressional
hearing
to
do a really wonderful thing
to expose the terrible side effects of
the fauci algae
Twitter files make it apparent Twitter
worked overtime to suppress accurate
coveted information Dr J bhattacharya is
a professor of medicine at Stanford who
once tweeted an article he wrote about
natural immunity thanks to Elon musk's
release of the Twitter files we learned
some of his tweets were tagged with the
label of Trends Blacklist apparently the
views of a Stanford doctor are
disinformation to you people
I along with many Americans have
long-term effects from Cova Not only was
I a long hauler but I have effects from
the vaccine it wasn't the first shot but
it was a second shot that I now
developed asthma that has never gone
away since I had the second shot I have
Tremors in my left hand and I have the
occasional heart pain that no doctor can
explain and I've had a battery of tests
I find it extremely alarming Twitter's
unfettered censorship spread into
medical fields and affected millions of
Americans by suppressing expert opinions
from doctors and censoring those who
disagree with the CDC I have great
regrets about getting the shot because
of the health issues that I now have
that I don't think are ever going to go
away
I love it preach lady that's great
especially coming from Nancy mace
because Nancy mace is not some rock
ribbed Conservative Republican far from
it she is one of the most Liberal
Republicans in the whole caucus and even
on this issue Nancy mace not that long
ago was going on CNN to promote the
experimental drug
I've been a proponent of vaccinations
and and wearing masks when we need to
and we had the Delta variant raging in
South Carolina I wrote an op-ed to my
community and I've worked with our State
Department of Health I've run ads
encouraging my district to go and get
vaccinated and when we have these
variants and we have these spikes to
take every precaution from washing our
hands to wearing the n95 or KN 95 masks
more than the medical Mass there is a
significant statistically significant
number of people that are protected from
coven when they wear those masks so it's
ironic that you've got Nancy mace at the
big Tech hearing complaining about
censorship of Miss and disinformation
she she did spread a lot of Miss and
disinformation and she I think she did
it honestly she spread the information
that she was uh unfortunately believing
from the Crooked left-wing Public Health
authorities and now after having done
that for quite some time she says wait a
second I got the stupid shot I regret it
I shouldn't have gotten it I have health
issues from it now and it's outrageous
that you big Tech you were censoring
information
the lesson here is that the best shot
that we have
of getting answers
to all of this the best shot that we
have at stopping the censorship
specifically of the medical information
on the internet
is
when the vaccine harms people in power
that's it I'm sorry to say it I'm sorry
that Nancy mace's suffering side effects
I'm sorry that lots of people are
suffering side effects from the
experimental drug that's a bad thing
it is simply a fact though
that the only way we're going to get to
the truth of this
we're going to expose the truth and
we're going to stop the censorship of
the truth
it's not when great Aunt Sally had side
effects from the vaccine it's not when
your kid gets myocarditis because his
school made him get the vaccine it's
when members of Congress have side
effects it's when
people with a platform and with the
ability to wield political power when
they deal with it that's when you're
going to get answers I said the other
day when we were talking about that
Viral clip of a little girl being beaten
up on a school bus I said
nothing's going to happen here there's
not going to be some new rule there's
not going to be some new law because the
people who make the rules and the laws
don't send their kids to those schools
so they just don't care it's too it's a
hot political potato they don't that no
one wants to touch this
if you touch it there's a risk you're
going to be called a racist people are
called racist for everything these days
it's expensive it's hard it's just
they're just not going to touch if their
kids went to those schools you know damn
well those schools would be fixed in
five minutes okay I think that's what
we're going to start seeing with the
vaccines now that people in power
or dealing with the side effects all of
a sudden you're going to see far less of
a push for the vaccine mandates now this
hearing on big Tech
was absolutely a magnificent there's
much to say about it as pertains to AOC
she had some real real face plant
moments uh and it was the highlight of
of the uh of the hearing I'm going to
get to more of it tomorrow there's one
that I have to get to that was AOC
complaining about
the Republicans complaining about the
suppression of the hunter Biden laptop
story
New York Post had this alleged
information and was trying to publish it
without any corroboration without any
backup information they were trying to
publish it to Twitter Twitter did not
let them and now they were upset I
believe that political operatives who
sought to inject explosive
disinformation with the Washington Post
couldn't get away with it
and now they're livid and they want the
ability to do that again they want the
ability to inject this again so they've
dragged a social media platform here in
Congress they're weaponizing the use of
this committee so that they can do it
again
a whole hearing about a 24-hour hiccup
in a right-wing political operation that
is why we are here right now and it is
it it's just an abuse of public
resources and abusive public time we
could be talking about health care we
could be talking about bringing down the
cost of prescription drugs we could be
talking about abortion rights Civil
Rights Voting Rights but instead we're
talking about Hunter Biden's half fake
laptop Story I mean this is an
embarrassment
there it is there it is so first of all
the factual claims she's making are not
true she says it was a half fake laptop
story it's not the hunter Biden laptop
story was completely 100 correct was not
a right-wing political operation or if
the right wing obviously liked the story
because it exposed the truth about the
Biden family in a lot of crimes
but
it was a true story they got it
completely right
and the libs censored it anyway
what AOC just said there at the end
though
was her Hillary Clinton moment what she
said at the end there was her
Benghazi hearing what difference at this
point does it make what do who cares who
cares about the hunter Biden laptop
story that was the commentary
the commentary from the hearing was oh
are we wasting our time who cares about
the hunter Biden laptop story
uh you do
you guys obviously care you obviously
cared enough to instantly weaponize all
of big Tech to censor this story
not just on the public platforms
you you got big Tech to to prevent
people from privately messaging the
story
you thought this story was such a big
deal the story that's been proven 100
true even Hunter Biden miss it now he's
suing actually he's in it wait a second
okay years later I'm willing to admit
that it was my laptop how did you get it
I'm gonna start suing you for it
you guys cared so much you thought that
this would be so detrimental to Biden's
presidential campaign polls after the
election showed that 12 percent of Biden
voters said had they known about the the
hunter Biden laptop story they would not
have voted for Joe Biden could have
could have been the difference between
Biden winning and losing
you guys cared that much and now you're
pretending that we're the ones who are
obsessed here this is what the libs do
all the time they say oh who cares about
transgender bathrooms
you do that's why you're trying to
change the bathrooms we conservatives
had no problem with men using the men's
room and women using the women's room
you're the one who made a big deal about
it you're the ones that started passing
all these crazy laws and showing up to
the state capitals and screaming and
crying and pretending that men are women
you you're the ones doing it
and conservatives should not fall for
this
do not fall for that that trick in that
trap
of saying well you guys if you if you
show any interest in this issue at all
you're you guys are obsessive it's your
Fanatics no
no we like the truth we care about the
truth you're the one starting all of the
aggression in the culture worth and now
you got caught we got you dead to rights
lady
last week I told you all had we got one
step closer to the crunch in our
breakfast cereal coming from Bugs and
not from whole grains the EU officially
enacted a statute allowing food
producers to incorporate Cricket powder
into its flower-based products not
because it tastes better but because the
political Elites have deemed that eating
the bugs is better for the environment
so right down to the food you eat the
world wants to make you woke but not
Dennis Prager he wants to make you wise
and the founder of prageru is going to
do just that in a never before seen
series exclusively on daily wire plus
called The Master's program with Dennis
Prager Dennis is a mentor with a wealth
of experience and what the master's
program aims to do is take 40 Years of
wisdom and experience from one of the
most influential conservative thinkers
today and distill it all down to its
Essence he covers such topics as the
consequences of secularism and is human
nature basically good
we're like I got to work on my Dennis
Prager but I gotta I have to just deepen
deepen it much more it's it's thought
provoking as it is Illuminating a brand
new episode of pragery Masters program
is available to stream right now
exclusively on daily wire plus head on
over to dailywireplus.com to become a
member and watch prageru's master's
program and much more daily wire
plus.com today
our economy is an absolute shambles
things are looking worse and worse and
when I need economic advice since I'm I
don't know anything about economics well
I've got a great resource that I can
call people have supported this show for
a very long time that would be our
friends over at Birch gold
the national debt is 31.5 trillion
dollars the FED met last week to promise
that everything's going to work out just
fine we've heard those promises before
hasn't hasn't always been great I can
barely afford eggs okay certainly not
the eggs that my wife wants to buy she
wants to buy the college educated eggs
that are not only raised in pastures but
also you know drive around in Corvettes
and and get foot massages so the economy
is in a very very difficult situation
and when I want to make sense of the
economy who do I call who do I call I
call my friends over at Birch gold group
specifically Philip Patrick who is the
precious metals specialist we had Philip
over I think it was
but maybe a year ago or so came on and
was able to illuminate my uh basic
economic ignorance and so I'm hoping
that we can have a similar effect again
thank you sir for coming on the show
thank you so much for having me it's a
pleasure so how am I supposed to make
sense of this because I remember 10
years ago I was really concerned about
the national debt it was a little more
than 10 years ago the conservatives
actually were talking about this issue
and that's back when debt to GDP was
about 90 percent today debt to GDP is
about 123 percent uh national debt
pushing up on 32 trillion dollars that's
about what ninety thousand ish per
citizen per citizen quarter million per
taxpayer because those are obviously two
different groups of people so
what does it mean for the future of the
economy I mean what does it mean that
that eggs now cost nine dollars a dozen
I mean look people are people are
feeling this day to day and we've got
this sort of very tough situation where
wages are not increasing anywhere near
close to the cost of goods and services
and essentially headline inflation that
becomes very problematic because that's
when people's paycheck doesn't do what
it did last month or the month before
it's a very tough climate that we're in
we're facing this concept of stagflation
right stunted economic growth coupled
with Rising inflation it's very painful
we had it 70s to 80s was the last time
here in the United States it's a perfect
storm we've got a lot of tough issues
coming together at once now Philip what
do you make of uh fed chairman Jerome
Powell saying that actually you don't
need to worry about increased inflation
I think he said that the disinflationary
process has begun you don't buy it
I just don't buy it at all right if we
dig into the numbers it's pretty obvious
we haven't seen very many meaningful
reductions so headline inflation has
come down a little bit but core
inflation and that is everything outside
of food and energy is really sticky
what's interesting though is looking at
where prices have fallen they've fallen
in exactly two categories one gas which
surged of course a year ago and now is
reverting back to the mean a little bit
and I think predominantly on the back of
demand destruction and used cars and
trucks right that's it everything else
pretty much has gone up
um so this idea that we have a handle on
inflation I think is a little bit of a
fallacy in fact former treasury
secretary Larry Summers came out and
pointed out he said look inflation is
still at levels that would have been
deeply alarming just two years ago more
than that though I think we've got to
look at the bigger picture right 89 of
CEOs are predicting a recession this
year we're seeing very large layoffs in
the tech sector corporate spending on
equipment is plunged now to the same
levels as the worst of the sort of
pre-pandemic panic my point is simply
that this Rosy picture strong jobs
reports or declining inflation it's a
little bit of an illusion and I think
CEOs who are operating in the real world
they know it and they're already
tightening their belts in anticipation I
think of a very tough few years ahead so
uh yeah tough times ahead do you think
that the the political debates going on
right now specifically over say the debt
ceiling which which is this recurrent
it's now perennial political debate and
the Republicans don't want to raise the
debt ceiling and the Democrats do and
then eventually they end up doing it
although now the GOP has the house so I
guess you know it could it could be a
little more tense do you think that is
going to have Syria economic
consequences
the debt ceiling debate is incredibly
important I mean you mentioned at the
beginning of this you know how debt has
expanded over the last 10 years debt to
GDP I mean the US's debt to GDP position
is in line with countries like Venezuela
and I mean it's bizarre at the moment
but the debt dealing the ceiling debate
is very very important right right now
as you mentioned we're sort of at this
impasse right the the Republicans are
saying look we're only going to raise
the debt ceiling if we we make some
cutbacks we curb their spending and the
Democrats are coming out and saying no
right we we don't we want to clean debt
ceiling height we want no conditions on
on the debt ceiling height now the
Republican side is one I understand
right we're amassing that they're saying
look if we're going to continue to spend
money we need to try and curb it in
certain areas and and sort of bring it
down it's the Biden regime's position
that I find very tough to understand
right they've drawn A Line in the Sand
they're saying look we don't want to
negotiate
this isn't a binary issue of principle
here we're not talking about abortion or
gun control we're talking about fiscal
discipline this is about balancing the
books coming to the table unwilling to
negotiate is a bizarre and quite frankly
indefensible position what they've
issued is essentially an ultimatum and
it's just not going to work talking
about what's at stake here though there
is a lot at stake right the debt ceiling
is the only limit we have on infinite
government spending the Federal Reserve
they can print infinite amounts of
dollars that's not the problem the
problem is that our leadership has been
running up debt ever since 2001. that
was the last year that income exceeded
expenditure here in the United States
and quite simply that cannot last
forever it is insustainable so this debt
ceiling debate is very very important
the Republicans won't allow a default
but they've got to force some
concessions it's a great point that that
unlike certain political issues this
isn't simply black or white you know an
issue of principle the fact that Biden
refuses to negotiate about about money
about dollars which obviously you know
if if we we can't come to some kind of
compromises and agreements about dollars
we're not going to do about anything but
but then even I don't want to let the
Republicans off the hook the fact that
the Republican leader has said that
entitlement reform is completely off the
table is I I get it entitlement reform
is not a popular political issue but
entitlements are 46 percent of the
federal budget so if you're not going to
touch entitlements the only way that you
could possibly get down to balancing the
budget would be to cut 85 percent of all
other spending which is impossible right
you're not going to get rid of all
effectively all government spending
other than a handful of entitlement
programs so so we're just we're just
sort of stuck and so what what are we
going to do we're just going to keep
amassing debt until our until our
dollars and our political influence
around the world is worthless
I mean sadly it's looking that way and
this is why it becomes an issue of
leadership but you're right it's both
sides of the fans like I said it's been
since 2001 that we haven't managed to
really get a handle on this we've had
Republicans and Democrats so this is a
political issue and we've got to curb it
at the end of the day over the last 300
years they've been 700 currencies and
they've gone one of two ways they either
significantly devalue through money
printing right pound sterling being one
of those or they disappear entirely so
this is a strange position it's not one
that we haven't seen before in history
but we want to keep our position as
Global Reserve currency world leader
this is a problem we have to get in
check and we have to do it now it's very
important I know that your expertise
obviously Philip is is in gold and I
being of Italians extraction know a
thing or two about gold myself you know
I'm not buying up quite as much as the
central banks are but but you know the
Italians they like some jewelry every
now and again so so I read somewhere
that uh we're seeing an uptick in Gold
buying from Global central banks is that
I don't know anything about that and I
certainly don't know what that means
an object is is is is absolutely the
case Central Bank uh worldwide or more
gold than they have in over 60 years so
I think the writing is is on the wall
central banks increasing gold Holdings
Russians Chinese Europeans as well what
we're seeing is a global trend of
d-dollarization and I think looking at
what the U.S federal reserve is doing
increasing the amount of dollars listen
eighty percent of dollars that exist
worldwide didn't exist three years ago
that's the scale of this policy right
look central banks around the world
they're holding dollars the more money
we print ultimately it leads to a
devaluation of those dollars and shorter
term gold is the way to hedge against
that when the dollar goes down gold
prices move up and I think what central
banks are doing is saying look the feder
printing money let's hedge some of that
exposure using gold what's true for them
is true for us as individuals albeit on
a much much smaller scale right you know
we're holding dollars as well those
dollars are losing buying power and gold
is one of the best ways to present
prevent that right they go up as the
dollar goes down they increase with the
cost of living so they're very good way
for governments to hedge dollar decline
but for individuals as well and that's
why we're seeing that Trend no I tell
you I I had this thought fortunately
right now in you know people obviously
want to have a diversified portfolio and
that includes especially if you're kind
of conservative in your economic
thinking that is going to include some
precious metals it's almost certainly
going to include gold I I was kicking
myself though because while I'm not I'm
not very exposed right now on on stocks
which is good that saved me some money
in recent years I've just got too much
cash and so you see you know as you see
uh I mean one never has too much cash
but but in terms of uh where you're
diversifying your portfolio if you've
got a lot of your money in cash
then when inflation hits at record
levels as it has in recent years you are
just burning money well I'm glad you
you've uh Philip underscored my families
and my cultures uh natural inclination
to uh to get gold uh not not just for
the pinky rings though you know maybe in
larger quantities than that Phil uh
thank you so much for coming on and uh
where can people learn more
it's very simple they text Knowles to
989898 again that's nulls to nine eight
nine eight nine eight and what that's
going to do it's going to give them
access to information because
information is everything once you know
the problems the solutions start to
present themselves so we're offering a
free information kit for your listeners
for your viewers uh they can come out
learn a lot about gold and once you know
the decisions become easier that's great
Philip Patrick thank you so much for
coming on as always we'll see you next
time there's an economic meltdown and I
need to pick your brain some more
I look forward to it thank you for
having me Michael
so just text notes to 98 98 98 we've got
a lot coming up on the member block it
is woke Thursday they're not supposed to
be woke Wednesday it's work Thursday
though uh the producers have a video
they say they need my expertise on
radical leftist culture at the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it become a member at dailywire.com
Knowles use code Knowles at checkout for
two months free on all annual plans
[Music]
foreign